bonjour christophe schmitt merci d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui sur arte france
alors tout d'abord comment expliquer ce
rebond d'incarcération ces derniers mois
bonjour et bien tout d'abord on fait
face à une comme l'a dit et comme cette
expliqué dans votre clip de présentation
à une reprise de l'activité judiciaire
qui a été importante
ces derniers mois et en parallèle de sa
aucune véritable politique carcérale
immobilière n'a été mise en oeuvre
jusqu'à présent on a eu des annonces au
mois d'avril de la part du premier
ministre expliquant le plan 15000 avec
une création de 15000 une nouvelle place
malheureusement il faut noter que ces
ouvertures sont souvent accompagnées de
fermetures en parallèle et qu'à côté de
ça les échéances et les projections nos
amène à des périodes comme 2025 2027
c'est donc aujourd'hui ils ont fait face
à une reprise de l'activité judiciaire
sans moyens supplémentaires pour pouvoir
héberger la population la population
carcérale et ça se note grandement dans
l'est surtout dans les établissements de
type maison d'arrêt alors la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme avait
déjà rappelé la france à l'ordre en
janvier 2020 quant à sa surpopulation
carcérale quelques mois plus tard de
nombreux prisonniers était libéré pour
cause du coc u19 est ce que justement la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
pourrait
éventuellement sévir sur sur cette
surpopulation carcérale en ce moment en
france elle pourrait mais ça ne mènera
pas de solution dans l'immédiateté et
surtout pas de solutions concrètes à la
situation qu'on vit aujourd'hui parce
qu'en plus de ça les chiffres que vous
avez présenté date du 1er juillet et on
constate dans l'est dans les
établissements alors je fais un
distinguo entre les maisons d'arrêt et
les maisons dites pour peine donc les
maisons dans l'ailé les établissements
qui sont voués à accueillir les détenus
pour des peines plus longues qui eux ne
sont pas confrontés aux mêmes
problématiques
la surpopulation carcérale les matelas
au sol c'est principalement dans l'est
dans les établissements maison d'arrêt
qu'on les connaît maintenant à côté de
ça si l'accord open les droits de
l'homme engagé des poursuites envers la
france elle le ferait et les
condamnerait la france s'est soumis à
payer des amendes mais en l'état ça ne
changera absolument pas la situation
qu'on vit aujourd'hui dans les
établissements pénitentiaires en france
alors là les prisonniers et les gardiens
de prison dénonce des conditions souvent
à déplorable de nombreuses personnes
incarcérées ensemble dans les mêmes
cellules des problèmes de drogue des
agressions violentes également est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui le système pénitentiaire
a perdu le contrôle ça date pas d'hier
notre organisation syndicale et
fo-pénitentiaire tire la sonnette
d'alarmé depuis un long moment
nous ce qu'on demande c'est la
classification des établissements de
manière à pouvoir travailler de manière
plus pragmatique avec une orientation de
détenus qui coïncide avec un
établissement pouvant gérer ce type de
détenus
la création place mais une création de
places qui n'est pas obligatoirement non
plus accompagné de fermeture à côté on
prend un exemple concret sur notre
région du grand est s'ouvrir à l'automne
un nouveau centre pénitentiaire qui est
voué à remplacer les maisons d'arrêt de
colmar et de mulhouse
malheureusement cette cette nouvelle
création d'établissements suffira à
peine à absorber la population carcérale
qu'on avait sur
vous et sur colmar donc des nouveaux
établissements hui mais des
établissements qui permettent de pouvoir
désengorger les structures existantes ce
qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
est ce que vous savez si la france est
le seul pays dans ce cas là à subir
cette surpopulation carcérale où c'est
la même chose pour nos voisins européens
par exemple il ya des pays en europe qui
connaissent également des problématiques
de surpopulation et vous en avez
d'autres qui par contre mènent des
politiques beaucoup plus pragmatique on
sûr sur la capacité d'accueil de nos
structures
maintenant la gestion faite en france
malheureusement on paye le prix d'une
non politique d'avenir de nos de nos
établissements pénitentiaires des moyens
octroyés aussi au personnel pour pouvoir
travailler dans de bonnes conditions
comme vous l'avez dit les personnels
sont confrontés quotidiennement à des
violences qu'elles soient physiques ou
verbales à devoir interférer et de voir
s'immiscer dans des trafics dans ce dans
ce genre de choses
la situation est extrêmement compliqué
il n'y a aucune reconnaissance pour les
personnels et conditions de travail
deviennent de plus en plus difficiles et
malheureusement on voit pas le bout du
tunnel et aucun signe aujourd'hui nous
permet de dire que la situation va
s'améliorer dans les mois qui viennent
merci christophe mais d'avoir répondu à
nos questions aujourd'hui sur arte
france rappelle et que vous êtes
secrétaire international fo
pénitentiaire grand test prison merci
beaucoup